Uh,
I would like very briefly to come
back to Weber's theory of domination.
I deleted it from the questions,
but I promise IVL get this back in
one way or another for the next test.
So probably the last thing you
want to think about now is a test.
Uh, but let me still talking
about the theory of domination.
I think there's is a
very important to Uri,
extremely influential
and extremely insightful.
So,
uh,
led me just very briefly sum up where we
left it last time and then I move into
Weber's theory of traditional authority.
And the last time we were talking about
the Crucial Distinction Vapor makes
beats being mocked and
hair shaft a martyrdom is
translated in English as power.
That is no question about this,
uh,
the translation of hair shaft
to various, uh, if there's, uh,
translated either as authority or
if this translated as domination.
Um, and I think most
translation, uh, are good.
Um, I think, uh, people, um,
or whom I feel closer in my own vapor
reading a translated more like domination
rather than or authority. Um, uh,
and in fact, uh, I think,
uh, just to emphasize you,
the importance of the, uh,
translation or difference,
um, in the notion of hair
chuffed, the first four letters,
Hara means the Lord.
So I think the notion
of hair shaft, uh, uh,
has a very strong implications of
asymmetrical power relationships.
Uh,
uh,
but I think domination
captures better than authority.
Those who translated Weber's
notion of how shaft as authority,
like a dark world,
Parsons wanted to emphasize that vapor,
um,
uh, uh, uh, looks at hair shaft, uh,
as something which is authoritarian
ride for somebody x out of authority,
right? Um, uh, this is, uh, uh,
not a false translation but
misses an important point.
And namely Weber's Interdis Indivi
how power is being exercised,
uh,
invested in a VA misses a Max
Weber's rules in the Frederick Nicha,
uh, or blah, blah, blah.
Eva and I made there.
So in the hops, uh, right,
human history is all about the
history of struggle for power.
That's in mighty think,
Weber's fundamental idea,
bow RV,
that important modification.
And I gave you the
citation a last lecture,
but let me come back to this.
Power means the likelihood
that people will obey order,
uh,
even against resistance and domination
means the likelihood that people,
veal actually follow orders,
these are being coerced to do so.
Uh,
so the notion of domination or hair shaft
does imply a degree of voluntary ness
and minimum level of belief that in fact,
those who issue order do have the
right to do so or at is at least it is
reasonable that they issue orders and I
follow the orders or to come up with an
even more minimal definition of how shaft
that I cannot see any real alternative
under the present circumstances,
but to obey the orders to the
volume who issues these orders.
Right. Uh, so, uh,
and this has everything to do
with the idea of legitimacy.
And I put a, uh, at last lecture
at his little equation, right?
Um, uh, on one of the slides, uh,
that power plus legitimation
adds up to domination,
uh, or, or authority.
So what is legitimation?
Viber said power is
really an extreme case.
That very little, very, it
happens very rarely, uh,
that the von who exercises or authority
exercise is simply by exerting power
coursing people to obey those
who are in position of authority,
uh, or try to legitimize rate, uh,
that autonomy or authority and tried to
come up with reasons by people subjected
to these authority should
obey that authority.
It's again, very niche
Yan, the idea, right,
that those who are exercising
power tries to internalize your,
a subjugation to power in one way
or another and try to create in you,
in you and mortality,
right?
A set of principles by
which you would say, well,
uh,
this may be the right thing for me to do.
Or as I said,
the minimum that finish.
And even if you don't particularly
like obeying order, you say,
what else can I do?
The alternative if I don't
obey order would be verse, uh,
or about the person
who issues or totality.
You may not lie the person who issues
authority, but you've, you'll say,
but the alternative is verse,
right?
So you can pick a course.
You may not lie the lecturer or that
March or the way how it creates,
well I've done other of course is you
did shop for and they've hurt even worse.
So you will be the least verse course,
right?
You pick the lecturer who seems to be
the least boring and too seems to be the
most reasonable grading you or assignment,
right?
That does mean that you are all that
thrilled to be at lectures and to do
assignments,
but you have to do it and under the
circumstances you go for the last email,
right?
That's I think the kind of most extreme
interpretation of Weber's idea of
legitimacy. But we were also,
I pointed this word out to you.
They were sad that all legitimacy
contains an element of a myth.
It doesn't mean that the person who
tries to justify its accorded the is
studying the troops,
whether it is through.
So naturals is almost besides the point,
the most important issue is that it
creates a methodology about the reason why
you have to obey authority.
So what I would cry to underline
already in last lecture,
that Weber's notion of legitimacy
is so much more sophisticated,
so less liberal and so much more me chair.
Then the idea of the normally hear,
then you hear the word legitimize
Shan by legit dimension.
We see something very good,
right?
A power is legitimated because it was
somebody who was elected in fair and three
elections, uh, to an office.
And we believe that this
person will do a great job.
Having been elected,
well have a verb would be more likely
to think something like our shy,
uh, uh, under the circumstances barberry,
there is no alternative to Afghanistan.
But to have this guy as the
president though it's very doubt for,
you know,
what all those claims and bowed,
the legitimacy of the
system are being made,
the APP 50 march and the
ecology created around it. Uh,
but, uh, the advice,
the alternative is cow horse and even
these guys probably better than chaos,
which would happen. Other vies
and I, this is, uh, you know,
my dark leading our next neighbor.
Now,
as you can see,
of course the difference
from Marx is fundamental. Uh,
marks did see human history as
unfolding of more soft production.
It was all struggle around
ownership and means of production,
clash of economic interest for vapor.
It is not economic interest,
which drives human history
but struggle for power.
And he can describe different
systems of authority over time,
but it is all described,
uh,
on the quality and the
nature of those mythologies,
those in position of power
come up to legitimate,
but they are trying to
do to you. Right? Uh,
so that is one fundamental difference
between a marks and the vapor.
That is an other fundamental
difference. And uh, you'll be,
you'll have to, uh, uh,
bear this very much in mind as these
lecture on traditional authority on the
floors.
Though Weber's develops these
different types of a domination,
uh, primarily to describe
historic gotta change,
grander societies,
traditional authority,
charismatic, all loss authority, legal,
rational authority kind of describes
the evolution of humankind and has a
similar kind of flavor
than marks a subsect van,
small soft production,
but vapor does more than that.
These three types of authority do describe
or kind of organizations or social
units,
uh,
and today the Ken Clark about legal,
rational authority,
traditional authority or Charismatic
Authority in Contemporary Society,
though he will call liberal market
capitalism as the purest Stipe.
And what pure type is,
I've,
you're talking about this in a minute
of legal rational authority give you say
that even in Contemporary Society,
the have organizations which are
based on traditional authority.
The most obvious example
of traditional authority,
and bear it in mind when we will
be talking about this, uh, uh,
today is the family you'll live in had
the family is primarily bound together by
tradition, but the very
institution where you are in now,
universities do have a flavor
of traditional authority,
right?
Uh,
it has a kind of ethos with at least three
teachers believe that you have to pay
some respect to the teachers.
And we have core kind of
traditional rituals, right?
Which makes, uh, uh, the making
the functioning of our university.
Uh, in a way a traditional
organization, right?
There is the graduation ceremony when you,
there will be varying all these
funny, you know, um, uh, uh,
um,
uh,
academy dress and then you
are awarded at the Gri,
which is happening almost like a,
of wording.
Um, uh, Lord chip by the cream, right?
The president of you'll say by
the power invested in me. Uh,
and then by this power,
the o Cornforth do you ride the degree
of Bachelor of arts or a Bachelor of
Sciences? Right? Uh,
this is very much like confirming the
title of Lord ship a on somebody by the
queen of England,
by the powers vested in her.
Uh, okay. So therefore vapor
is more flexible. It marks,
it doesn't simply describe society,
but in every society it does describe
a certain organizations and in
contemporary society,
the often talk about charisma.
And we have been talking a lot about
Carrie's mine the last 18 months.
And we were talking about, uh, um, um, um,
barrack Obama and,
but Aqua Obama being gift
charismatic leader, right?
So the charisma is also something
what we very often in a walk today,
um, describing the
nature of authority, uh,
somebody, um, is, uh, exercising.
Okay. So that's again, you know,
just the backdrop to the notion
of authority and I hope it feel,
help you to locate it,
uh, more, uh, in, uh, uh,
the, uh, uh, literature.
Now as I mentioned also in last lecture
that are c major types of authority,
traditional authority
in which basically the,
you have a personal master in charge
and dispersing our master somehow pos to
old age or,
uh,
sank a sacred rules,
to ask you to obey his or her commands.
Mostly yes.
But occasionally her commands after all
that is a green in England that were
queens in England for a long time.
Okay.
So that's the additional authority.
Uh,
the other one is charismatic
authority where the person in charge,
um, uh, cause for obedience
on the grounds, uh, uh,
that,
uh,
that person is believed
to have some supernatural,
extra ordinary powers. Uh, um, um, uh,
uh,
and fine,
not illegal rational authority or
authority in which the person who is a,
um,
uh,
issuing command is also under the same
law as people who are obeying orders and
in legal, rational authority, you
do not have a personal master.
You do not obey a person,
but you obeyed the rules and laws.
That's why waiver costs legal
rational authority as a shorthand.
I think it would be more obvious to
call it liberal or authority or liberal
system of authority.
I just want to make one more vote.
One very brief comment.
Um,
as we proceed to traditional authority,
namely that the three types of
authorities are not exactly have the same,
uh, ontological status, uh,
vapor basically have two
major types of authority,
traditional authority or
legal rational authority.
Charismatic Authority does not have
the longevity of our traditional or
authority or legal.
Rational Authority has charismatic
authority as we are talking about this.
A great deal is a revolutionary force.
Charismatic Authority usually occurs
for the relatively brief period of time.
Typically the charismatic leader is a
one person and it is very lucky if that
one person can maintain the charisma for
all the time this person is in charge.
I mean,
uh,
just after nine months of the
election of President Obama,
we see a level,
right,
a withering of his sort of
strong charismatic Aptia.
So in order to maintain your charisma
for while you are in office and a
specialty for the lifetime
is very difficult and even
more difficult to transfer
his mom to another leader.
So charismatic authority is
really a change basically,
as I will argue later on from one form
of traditional authority to another form
of traditional authority
in the Maxim Baber.
So therefore are the two big types,
traditional authority and
legal rational authority.
And what Mark's God,
the transition from fewer dollars
into capitalism or what the understand
modernization is really nothing else but
the movement from traditional authority
to legal rational authority.
Okay. Uh, now let me go,
go,
uh,
into today's topic and dark
about additional authority.
And uh,
at first about pure type by Vr.
Describe his definition of the pure type,
but it needs a,
a fool to north about
pure type is all about
uh, uh, as I already pointed out,
Max Weber's was a Kantian.
Uh,
that meant that Max Faber did not
believe that a human knowledge,
which completely describes
the reality is possible,
right?
The reality is so infinity
the rich that the concepts,
what we develop is only mental
images of these objects.
What we are developing concept about,
right?
It can be never be fully
describing the subject.
So these mental objects,
what we have in our mind about the
object from which we tried to develop
knowledge is what he calls a ideal types
or they are abstractions from the bird,
not a precise description
of diverse world.
So therefore what he said the best,
what we can aim at to develop
ideotype pure types and or realities.
We all of us,
some are different from the idea of
type what is in our mind and as human
knowledge is progressing and
that's what makes actually be,
but at difficult reading is that the,
in the process of knowledge,
we develop an ideal type at conceptions.
About the world.
And then we go back to reality and we
see that he does not exhaust the reality
as it is the reality has
other important features.
The miss in the first instance.
So we go back and via Redo
our ideal type and rich,
the idea of type to fit to
create a better fit with reality,
right?
That's the fundamental idea.
And that's what makes Weber's so difficult
to read because he often comes up
bitten idea of type a
pure and he said yes,
but when I'm reading get historical
reality, it does not quite fit.
So therefore I redo a little my
idea of type and and rich it.
So you can easily get lost
when you are reading vapor.
And this is not accidental,
right? This is the methodology,
how he proceeds.
You does not believe that we can
attain absolute knowledge. Uh, what,
what,
what he believes that we have to
strive to be able to describe.
But we want to describe as precisely
as we just skim tech as we can.
So this is the idea of pure types.
So what is the pure type of legal,
rational authority or for
traditional authority?
And first of all, if you have to talk
about the basis of legitimacy, uh,
just very briefly,
something also about the veterans,
how Assaf is being recruited as such.
And we come with a very clear
and simple that definition, uh,
in traditional toricity legitimacy is
claimed for and believed in by virtue of
the sanctity of age old rules.
So the person who rules makes a claim
that this has been all of us this way,
and that is some sacred mess in,
in effect,
obeying the person who by age or
tradition was assigned to a position of
authority. And again, let me
just go back to the family.
This is a classical example.
The parents, uh, do, uh,
uh,
have some sacred law rights to issue
some commands and the do obey barons
because it has all of us this way.
Children,
all of us had to obey barons to
what extent they have to obey.
And what parents can do to children
may vary a little over time,
but the parents are in charge
and they are them. Uh, uh, um,
uh, in fact do have Darius to
issue certain kinds of commands,
is widely accepted,
but avert believed in is
also very important, right?
So the parents do not have to force you
to obey you beginning to believe that if
it is indeed right thing
that the parents obey order.
It happens also if you,
particularly in this life,
but they try to order and
occasionally you may not like, uh,
uh, one of your parents
or both of your parents,
never the less you think,
some degree of obedience is necessary
unless you really break the law and you
ran away, right? Um, but
that is, uh, uh, certainly,
um,
and extreme case as it is an extreme
case that parents will force children.
You will squashing, uh, of
children to obey that rule.
Well, occasionally they use
some degree of coercion.
It's also very important
in, in Viber. You know,
that question is all of us present in
every type of a domination neuro thing.
That legal rational authority does not
have coercion in the United States.
Over 3 million people are in jail,
right?
They are being coerced in
the United States. People,
occasionally I killed by the
government, right? The are executed.
So there is coercion,
even in legal,
rational authority in the most
liberal democratic society.
If you break the laws,
you have your B course,
and if you are not breaking the law,
that is always the promise of coercion,
right? It said, well, under certain
circumstances you'll hear because,
um,
now the second important point is right
that the master who obeys the order is
designated by traditional rule,
right?
And the are obeyed because
of that I convert that, um,
well I to do day is translated
into English as traditional status.
Uh,
it's not a very good translation.
I can build the really means that
they are believed to have virtuous by
themselves, that they have a virtue
of what they themselves carry out.
So there is honor and I think the
term honor is extremely important,
right? Um, uh, uh, for
understanding traditional authority,
uh,
the traditional master is always
assumed to be an honorable person,
right?
And if that person becomes non honorable,
it is likely that it will
use each authority. Again,
think about balance, right? Um,
the parents are supposed to be honorable
and if they are not honorable any
longer, that is a crisis
in the family. Um,
have you seen Arthur Miller's play?
The Das have the sales man?
This is exactly what happens in the depths
of the salesman when he song catches
the father whom he admired
so much is sketching him, uh,
that, uh, uh, another woman,
then his mother, right.
Then suddenly the father loses his
honor is not honorable any longer.
Right? And that creates a
lifelong crisis for the child.
So, um, uh,
I think honor is very important to
understand traditional authority and uh,
it is based, a traditional rule
is based on personal loyalty.
You personally feel that you
have to be loyal to this person.
Again,
all of these issues do apply to a
substantial degree in institutions like a
university. Right? Uh, uh, it,
there's also the kind
of assumed, right? Uh,
that professors should act in an
honorable way and if they don't,
uh,
they are cold or being not honorable,
they are VOB losing their,
uh, uh, a legitimacy.
And that is a great deal
of personal loyalty. Uh,
in university situations there are,
particularly in graduate school,
the relationship,
the mentor and the phd student is a highly
personalized relationship off neutral
loyalties. Uh, right. Uh, um,
there is so much a mentor you'll be
able to take that a PhD student in the
dissertation will be true critical of
the professor who is supervising the
dissertation.
It accepts some degree of loyalty right
from the student and the student would
be very disappointed and if he turns out
that the mentor is writing bad letters
for him, right? There is
an expectation, right,
of mutual loyalty in every
type of traditional authority.
Uh,
and what is therefore important.
That is also a personal element whom you
obey is a kind of a person or master,
not simply a supervisor,
not a boss,
but something of a person
or most of a master,
an honorable person to whom
you are linked. The two, uh,
by uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, uh, loyalty.
Well, how do you recruit
staff under this, uh, uh,
a system that are really
two ways to do it.
That is a so called battery
morning or recruitment, um, uh,
namely that people are
selected into position, uh,
because the are related to the
chief, uh, uh, by tradition,
uh, because they are known
to the chief. Um, uh,
this happens still green deal in
various organizations even today.
Um, especially university
organizations do exercise, uh,
substantial, uh, patrimonial
system of recruitment,
but there are extra petrie morning or
vase when persons are judged to be loyal
by the master.
And I pointed to the office because
all of their expected loyalty or such.
Again, I can give you the example
of the universities that are,
a lot of recruitment is happening through
battery morning. Our recruitment, uh,
you are well in the u s universities,
you are not supposed to recruit your
own students in Europe. They do, uh,
uh,
in the U s few universities.
Do you recruit the students of your body,
so your,
your friends or your colleagues,
right.
It's a lot of battery morning
autism going on in university, uh,
recruitment and in fee.
In fact,
loyalty is very important when it comes
particularly to the appointment of
administrators in the university system.
Uh,
now that odd I let me move on and
let's have the broader historical view.
There are various historical variations.
So after additional authority,
uh,
VBA is very messy in terms of terminology.
I was trying to make as
much sense as I could.
I think that our two major
forms of traditional authority,
one is Scott Patriarchaly Zuma and
the other one is Scott Beci morning.
I'll domination.
The big difference between patriarchal
systems that it does not staff,
um, uh, that uh,
what is being the authorities exercise
directly by the master and does not need
a staff in order to exercise,
eat authority.
Patrimonial domination on the
other hand does have a staff,
it is a larger scale society
on a larger scale organization,
better staff view or carry out
the commands of the master.
This is the distinction between masters
staff and the people who obey is
extremely important for Max Ray.
But,
and try to get deep down in your
brain these comment because you cannot
understand the vaporium visa. This,
as I pointed out, the neighbor said,
that is of us a degree of belief
or faith involved in legitimacy.
But what kind of fate
depends a great deal.
Whether the fate is by the staff in the
master or by the people in the master
they burst. Fundamental idea is
that the system is legitimate.
As long as the staff has a
positive belief in the master.
I had the masses.
The people you shortly do not have
a positive belief. They don't.
You'll surely love the person who rules.
Then they just accept
it as the lesser evo,
but the staff has to have a
positive belief in the master.
Then do to come at revolution comes
then the staff is losing faith in the
master,
then the Shah of Iran a fail.
Then the second unity services in
Iran begin to lose faith in the shock.
The people of Iran, he was short. He
did not lie there shot all that much.
They just could not think of an
alternative should they accepted it,
but the regime fell when the
security services lost faith in them.
The same can go for the fall of communism,
communism fell of and the Communist
Party staff and the specialty.
The secret services begin
to lose faith in the system.
Not that most people who
lived under communism,
all that bloody communists,
right bath,
bow the staff Os than the staff turned
out to be again coming on his best when
communism fell,
they'll be three.
Patriarchal is my view and
make to this distinction here.
Primary Patriarchal is man get on top
crecy and then about pitch and morning of
domination about pure patrimonial Islam
that the staff is purely a personal
instrument in the master.
And finally,
SD type of domination.
It wasn't,
we normally call few [inaudible] event,
the administrative staff and appropriate
certain powers from the master.
Uh,
and now what I do or you to show,
I think what Weber's theory of
history is how these different types,
uh,
for systems evolve.
He said the history begins
with B three or charisma. So,
but relatively small societies,
for instance, kinship networks,
they're the elders or the fatter can
rule the society and does not need
policemen. Jailers, you know, judges,
administrators, stack school
actors in order to run the SAF,
it does indirectly,
uh,
then it moves to a primary Patri
morning. Al Islam, they're,
the society becomes
larger. Uh, there is staff,
but the staff is individually selected
by the master and the the completely
depend by their master.
Their most extreme example of this is
as I view a dark about this in a minute,
salt on Islam and that the salt and can
actually get credit and we'll typically
get shreds of the staffer at Veale and
very frequently then it is moving to
feudal type of nomination that the staff
appropriate certain powers from the
master appropriates those
powers because uh, um,
for instance it has lent holding what
is given to a noble family not only for
life but also for the laminate family,
for the life of the family. Right.
The feudal property has been inherited
and then the staff appropriate certain
powers, uh, from, uh, the
master will act as a master,
for instance, even serve
justice. And finally,
legal rational authority. Uh, there,
the of coercion is the
monopoly of the stage.
No individual has the right to exercise
scores if power except the state.
Well, this is not quite true.
Bet. Dance, for instance,
still I have summarized,
we ha we feel uncomfortable about this,
but parents do have summarize
to exercise coercion,
but generally you cannot
exercise any coercion,
only the state can.
So as you can see in a way the history
of humankind is an evolution of the means
of coercion by four marks.
The question was the evolution of the
means of production for the bird history
live in by the evolution of the
means of administration and coercion.
Again,
a very niche area and idea and that
dark read of the history that history
actually is getting worse because
those who will have more and more
sophisticated means to suppress
a larger number of people.
And what makes it even worse?
They internalize you,
internalize your own
submission internally.
You believe that this is the right
thing, that you are not free, right?
That's again,
I think the [inaudible] view of history
in my reading now about patriarchal
asthma is the most elementary
form. As I said. Um, uh,
um, when, uh,
we believe rider that is one
master without the staff, uh,
who has, uh, the right
to exercise or there's a,
because that it is no
staffer, uh, it is, uh, uh,
assume that the members of the group,
which is under patriarchy,
charisma, for instance, a kinship
networks, um, uh, has a, uh,
substantial, uh, feeling, uh,
that they actually should obey
these master of Aber caused them.
They are there no set. They are
comrades. There is a camaraderie, right?
This is a family, right? The family
has some degree of pharmacists.
They are not, uh, uh,
he said [inaudible] they are
not subject to authority,
but they are comrades, right? They
are members of our community. Um,
uh,
but I'm very patriotic.
Holism means when there
is a, uh, uh, typically,
uh, father, uh, kind of rule,
uh,
the father rules,
typically it's that there may have
been maternal authority as well.
Uh,
the historical record is a bit unclear
whether there were matriarchal societies,
uh,
we can assume the reverse.
So then they have their patriarch
or matriarch has societies.
It was a mater who ruled the
family or the WHO ruled the family.
And uh, uh, uh, the relationships,
we are not necessarily based on blood
relationship because actually it's what I,
very long time we did not know
that the sexual act may have,
uh, or that Mush duvet
procreation. It, uh, recent,
a reasonably recent discovery of human
scientific knowledge that this happened.
And therefore in very early societies
it was not known at that there is blood
relationship between the father
and the children. Um, uh,
even then it did hold, uh, uh,
well once up cases of course slavery,
I leave it out,
but let me talk about
getting get on ocracy.
There are some systems
in which the elders rule,
the older person has the authority.
Um,
uh,
Valerie get on docker oracy is against
something which is not on her door for a
modern societies as well.
Now let me move on to battery morning.
I'll domination.
Um, yeah. Um, and uh, uh,
uh, it does emerge. Typical, yeah,
merge fan and administrative
staff is being created.
This is a larger societies.
You need armies on policemen
than tech school actors.
In order to operate,
and the members who are subordinated to
your authority are treated as subjects.
Uh, I mean, I'm also her
majesty's subject. Uh,
you know, when I got to run, so
Australian citizenship and then, uh,
um, uh, you know, the Korean is
the other Korean of Australia,
so I'm her majesty's subject,
not simply an Australian citizen.
Right? Uh, then there is
a person with whom I'm,
the authority is relied on in some
days in England and in Australia.
It's the figure of the queen who
does that, right? Uh, uh, well,
uh, I don't want to deal with this
because I'm running out of time, right?
Uh, initially, uh, three
are called domination,
but patrimonial domination. It was
really just a large household and the,
in fact, uh, but the, the, you know,
ruler the king or unburned did he event
from one village to the next and be the
staff and was fat for life
in a household and moved on.
But then of course, uh, it became
more complex. Uh, and then,
uh,
had to create a state.
I had to create a state in which a
moves beyond the oil costs and taxes are
being collected.
Um, um, um, and, uh, uh, uh, uh,
uh,
it, uh, it's surrounding
[inaudible] be like kind of, uh,
a bureaucracy, um, now, uh,
in a pure type of battery morning,
all domination, right? The, uh,
the, uh, staff are purely, uh,
instruments in the hands of the
master and life. I'm mentioned.
Salt on Islam is bad.
That is virtually on the restaurant.
The power for the ruler to replace,
uh,
uh, uh, duals under each
authority as it pleases,
but then, uh, uh, uh,
evolves in history and
more complex system, um,
SD type of domination or a few dollars,
ma.
And it is a system in
which, uh, um, uh, uh,
um, uh, cost it to SD type of domination,
uh, uh, in which, uh, uh, uh,
the staff has certain degree of stability.
Um, uh, uh, uh, now how
much stability, uh, it has,
uh, um, uh, if you're depend, uh, uh,
how the staff is being rewarded and a
vapor makes a crucial distinction between
benefits is and fiefs.
Uh, these other two ways,
how the staff, uh, uh, uh, can be, um,
at evolved deed, uh, in, uh,
an estate type of donation,
a fee for a uveal easily remembered that,
right?
Avi Use the term in ordinary language
we say somebody has a fee for Dorma.
And by this we mean if
somebody has a fever dorm,
it means that somebody created the,
uh,
a subsystem Uber, which
it has gone through, uh,
virtually as long as that position is
alive was as that position is at least in
the same organization. Uh, so again,
if I can use the university examples,
you may not be as familiar
with this as I am,
but in universities,
for instance,
a office space for faculty
is a typical fees long. Uh,
once, uh, you know, in
faculty got an office,
it's virtually impossible to take
the office away from somebody.
It created a fief Dong a over
the territory of what that,
uh, what that person
has a, this is, uh, uh,
only for the time of the tenure.
Of course,
somebody retires that officers
will be immediately taken away.
The fiefdom is lost.
But you know,
the notion of fiefdom means that
you have lasting powered on it.
Benefits on the other hand
means that you get certain,
but all of the,
under the conditions that you
actually do the liver, uh,
uh, uh, uh, uh, to the ruler.
And there are really two types of feudal,
uh,
uh, systems. Uh, uh, one
is, uh, uh, a base. The,
um, on benefits is, um, and this is a,
a kind of a Rubendall for forum,
a few dollars. That means,
uh, the ability we serving
the SAR. For instance,
Russia was ruled, uh, typically, uh,
after Yvonne the terrible, my
namesake, uh, and until, uh,
uh,
the Russian revolution by a kind of
prep Bendel's system in which a desire,
uh, gave, uh, um, uh,
as data to the Lords as long
as they were loyal to it. Uh,
Eh, we see this now happening
in Russia again. Um,
President Putin actually to the
billions of dollars of Val's,
uh,
what people receive the from President
Yeltsin as private property because he
did not think they are loyal.
So these people ended up in jail
or they were sent into emigration.
Their property was taken away.
So even contemporary Russia in a VA
operates almost like a breath and,
or type of few dollars more, right? Uh,
President Putin as a kind of Evander
terrible right to sort of reinforces
loyalty. Uh, uh, and,
uh, I made the point,
right? That was exactly as
in Russia changed, uh, the,
a few of those system. Um,
and then, uh, [inaudible], uh,
uh,
were turned into Polish chics
boilers in Russia before Ivan,
there's charitable, had
inherited valves, um,
and Evander terrible and Peter the great
took that obey and turned them into
serving nobility in exchange for loyalty.
Uh,
if you have a listen to
Mussorgsky's fantastic opera,
Boris Godunov, you get the
story that he, exactly.
If you have not listened to it,
do right.
Don't get a year degree not
having known both. Uh, uh, uh,
and we saw us is fantastic. Upper
Boris Godunov. Um, all right.
Uh, well, uh, western a few dollars
more on the other hand is based, uh, uh,
on, uh, uh, uh, uh, long glass thing.
Get powers of the staff.
Uh,
a vest and feudal lords received a
property for lifetime and it actually was
inherited, uh, by the, uh, children. Uh,
and the fell.
They also exercise a great
deal of administrative power,
light,
uh,
feudal lords in France or England did
held court and made judgments right over
there. They're serves those who
belong to that authority. So the, uh,
and the kings were rather
limited in their power.
Uh, Valerie have seen this struggle
earlier in this scores, right? Uh,
between, uh, the king's
trying to gain more authority,
take it back from the feudal lords.
That's all that,
uh, um, uh,
absolute is versus constitutional
monarchy was all about right now,
of course for a constitutional
monarchy was not simply
the, uh, feudal lords who are assisted,
but also order the,
the bourgeoisie who wanted to have
a constitutional monarchy to limit,
uh, uh, uh, the rights of the monarch.
Now a traditional Tori
or Tony does a authority,
doesn't go very well with the economy,
right?
Because it is primarily oriented towards
satisfaction of needs and not the
generation of the profit.
Uh, right. And, uh,
therefore, uh, uh,
traditional domination
is likely to prevent the
development of business oriented
activities. And that's, I think, again,
true for the more
traditional type of system.
But we are familiar with like
the family or the universities.
Uh, they do not fight, operate,
lie business corporations,
um, uh, and, uh,
therefore the, uh, uh, uh,
may, uh, make, uh, uh,
calculate economic calculation
and profit seeking, uh,
difficult or impossible. Um, uh,
they can be a defense against
market Mac market mechanism,
but do not promote, promote a
mark Marquette mechanism. Uh,
uh, um, uh,
and of course in all
of these organizations,
that is a larger degree of arbitrariness.
Then in modern,
uh, organizations, uh, uh, uh,
and of course in traditional organization,
that is all of us a greater, uh,
um,
uh,
respect to the vowel fear of those
who are subjugated to authority.
So that's about traditional authority
and the extension of its modern
capitalism.
Thank you.